hallo ihr lieben heute gibt es die zweite
folge von meinem format ich teste tik tok
rezepte die wir eingegangen sind heute
zwei herzhafte und ein süßes rezept
und ich bin gespannt ob sie uns auch
schmecken ich mache jetzt zuallererst
die pizza sticks das hat eigentlich wenig
mit pizza zu tun das ist vielmehr wieder
so einen pass da trennt und dafür werde
ich jetzt zuallererst pasta gar kochen
passt das dix das sind gar gekocht die werden
hier aufgespießt und mit namen marinade oder
mit passierten tomaten bestrichen dann kommt
noch leckere toppings drauf und dann wird das
ganze schön jeezy weil der ganze käse drauf
kommt und es die super lecker aus ich bin
gespannt für die sauce habe ich mich dafür
entschieden einfach passierte tomaten zu
nehmen da kommt jetzt salz pfeffer und zucker
rhein bei tomaten oder tomate die waren immer
ein bisschen zucker mit dazu dass hamburg
jetzt super und was ich noch dazu nehme sind
italienische kräuter und berichtet dann ist
die soße praktisch schon fertig ist auch echt
ein witz rezept und dann spiele ich schon mein
gemüse ich nehme heute paprika und lauchzwiebeln
also die nudeln jetzt einfach auf zwei
schaschlik spießen aufspießen und ich nehme
zwei damit einfach ein bisschen stabiler
ist ich habe jetzt auch schon direkt auf
ein mit backpapier ausgelegtes backblech
gegeben und jetzt kommt der spaßige teil
ist werde ich hier die passierten tomaten
einmal gleichmäßig darauf verteilen und
dann okay all'italiana weghören aber es
wird wie schon so ein bisschen an pizza
weil dann geben wir noch ganz viel käse um
drüber und zum schluss dann den ganzen belag
also eigentlich überlege ich gerade jetzt
hab ich's eingestrichen ich glaube ich
drehe die um bestreicht dann noch mal und
macht dann käse und so weiter noch darauf
die pizza sticks werden hiervon vorgeheizten
backofen bei 200 grad ober und unterhitze für
ungefähr 14 bis 16 minuten goldbraun gebacken ich
habe mir einfach spontan überlegt da kommt noch
ein tipp dazu darf habe ich einfach schmandt
genommen wir können doch creme fresh lemon
dürft auch joghurt nehmen da gebe ich jetzt
knoblauch dazu außerdem ein bisschen salz
und eine kräutermischung und zwar habe ich mir
gedacht café de paris wurde hier ganz gut passen
tasty hamza ich weiß wie freundlich alles
nicht aufrichtig nach sonja drinnen wird
gedacht aus dem backofen also wer cremige passt
dann liebt für den ist das jetzt wahrscheinlich
nicht weil es war dass ich weiß es gar nicht
gibt so gemacht und einfach rein weißen
also auf jeden fall interessant erst 1 0
cremig aber es ist gut gewürzt muss sagen
es tut noch mal hier rein ich bin jetzt einfach
hier weil ich glaube mit dem knoblauch zusammen
es ist auch eine gute kombi ist cool aber ich
glaube dass die kinder etwas was cool ist was
was oder so aus dass besteht ein sicheres
gerade das ist mega handlich wegen diesen
schaschlikspieß irgendwie unhandlich wenn man
angst hat dass es runter fällt aber mit dem dip
zusammen richtig lecker hat ein bisschen macht
von fäkalien schmeckt sehr gut aber können auch
zusammen mit kinderwägen und angelaufen so auf
hochzeit ist oder irgendeine feier party und
hast du liegt dieses risiko aus da sind auch
schlecker aus aber er ist so als alltäglich
für das ich nie als so mancher vater auf dem
party befehl ich glaube das geht als erstes weg
und ich auch so weiter geht es mit rezept
nummer zwei und ich bin richtig gespannt ob
es überhaupt schmeckt wir machen nämlich wo
ich bin ich bin nicht so ein fan von bruno
hat aber auch das normale wohin du lieb ich und
dafür braucht man eigentlich gar nicht so viele
zutaten für das bruno wiedmann dass sie einfach
die bonus zerstampft werden dann kommt da milch
rhein ein löffel und dann ab in die gefriertruhe
erstmal braucht man nur die boeing und sahne und
milch ich nehme es sich nur mich damit nicht
so wässrig schmeckt und gebe jetzt die sahne
einfach direkt dazu früher das kurz und dann werde
ich die bonus erst mal richtig schön zerstören
also bei den zweier boeing muss kann man ganz
gut so ein löffel reinstecken ich habe jetzt
hier nochmal diese einer wohin los und da
könnte man entweder einen schaschlikspieß
oder so ein eis stil einfach mit da reingeben
und direkt danach wird es eingefroren also
tief gefroren und das dauert also ca 4
stunden und dann ist auch schon fertig
danke wenn du hier bist da ist dann hinter der
kamera das weiß ich nicht wer hilft
uns geradeaus doch nicht mein gott
so ich mache jetzt doch noch eine vollmilch
hülle dafür einfach die kuvertüre schön fein
hacken und dann über dem wasserbad erwärmt für
die schokolade habe ich übrigens temperiert und
habt ihr keinen grauschleier also erstmal
zwei drittel erwerben über dem wasserbad
und dann das restliche drittel unterrühren ich
habe das jetzt mal ein glas gefüllt und werde
jetzt die tiefgefrorenen sticks einmal raus
nehmt ihr könnt es auch super einfach jetzt
von der verpackung entfernen zunächst einmal
rein trunken das ist richtig satisfied danach
ist gut abtropfen und gibt es direkt auf mein
backpapier und ich werde gleich noch dekorieren
ihr könnt das mit haselnüssen dekorieren oder
da ihr ja schon alle sagt meine haselnuss creme
schmeckt schon wieder das innere von renault
bietet es sich natürlich perfekt an einfach
die haselnuss creme noch mal oben drüber zu
machen wenn die nicht möchte dass ihr solche
schoko füße habt dann einfach nach kurzer zeit
also ich mache was ich schon immer wegziehen und
neu platzieren dann gibt's einfach ein bisschen
schicker aus so ich hab jetzt die haselnuss creme
noch mal ganz kurz erlernt in der mikrowelle
denn so kann man es viel besser regulieren
also das ist jetzt moreno das wird wohl nur ein
ruck und rate euch nimmt die eine die zweier also
die brauchen viel mehr kühl seite würde ich
sechs acht stunden weil sie solche sängerin
lass uns die einer nehmen ausgeschlossen
ist ja dadurch dass sie auch die soft boxen
die annahme sehr schnell geschmolzen einfach
wenn es schmerzt schon es ist sehr warm hier
überwindung geschmack kommt direkt in diese
waffe hin du schmeckst die rechtliche waffeln
ich muss sagen ich bin christ ist und
weil das ist das muss in serie also ich
finde sozialprojekt überhaupt nicht wieder
ich finde es schmeckt ganz irdischen ganz
anders ich mit leidenschaft als der schminke
richtig es ist ja auch gut auf schaefer mehr
kühlt seid und wir haben es jetzt auch erstmal
haben so erst mal fotografiert und so was also
wenn ich zu hause macht dann könnt ihr das
sofort gekauft da scheint echt lecker aber
einen daumen hoch für dieses rezept das macht
auf jeden fall nach 16 von cigna aber macht
die einer nicht die zweier noch auf jeden fall
die einer die kann man noch besser tunken sie
macht gibt mir so wir starten jetzt mit unserer
want ob pasta das heißt wir brauchen nur einen
kommt also in meinem fall eine hoch an fahne
und da gehen wir jetzt alle zutaten rein und
dann wird das ganze mit wasser aufgegossen und
aufgekocht ich schreibe euch übrigens alle ganz
genauen mengenangaben unten in die infobox damit
ihr euch jetzt natürlich nichts mit schreiben
ist also für die tik tok passe das ist extrem
wir eingegangen da wird einfach creme fraiche
mozzarella basilikum tomatenmark und noch gewürze
es wird alles mit rohr pasta von milch dann kommt
noch gemüsebrühe dazu und dann wird auch noch
so lange gekocht bis die pasta da sind und bei
creme fraiche könnt ihr auch entspannt nehmen
frischkäse eigentlich alles was so cremig ist
sowas den käse angeht im rezept steht mozzarella
ich nehme jetzt beides er sich im emmental könnte
doch gouda dem und mozzarella denn ich finde
ihr mehr käse desto besser und beim basilico
könnt ihr frischen oder auch getrocknete nehmen
bei dem rezept ist ja kein und keine zwiebeln
und kein knoblauch materien ich bin deshalb sehr
gespannt auch mir das dann trotzdem gut schmeckt
also in dem tic toc video habe ich gesehen das war
glaube ich wgh also ist auch ein fertiger so ritz
mischung habe ich jetzt nicht da und ich nehme
jetzt ganz gerne einmal gemüsebrühe da ist ja auch
schon ordentlich salz mit drin deshalb beim walzen
sehr vorsichtig sein was er mir auch nicht fehlen
darf ist paprika edelsüß auch ordentlich rein
ja und halt salz und pfeffer und das war es auch
schon das ganze dann mit wasser auffüllen lassen
es dann so lange köcheln des die lügen garten
also ich mag schon heute wenn zum beispiel das hat
richtig lange gedauert und ich echt anstrengend
ist zu machen ja das bin ich dem bekommen was
wirklich sehr angespannt wie sie schmeckt ich
mich schon so viel strom gebraucht war das match
okay das kann ich nach dem einzel ticket alle
gemeinsam das sind immer bild rezepte forschendes
heftig heftig gut ich bin extrem würzig wo viele
also vieles macht er jetzt auch der mozzarella
aus tomatenmark und paprika mark im tik tok
rezept was no tomatenmark ich habe paprika noch
mit dazu genommen es ist schon sehr würzig ich
nicht also die die zubereitung zweieinhalb
minuten und dann habe ich schon gesagt 20
minuten an auf dem herd und ich hab den deckel
abgenommen nach ein paar minuten schon damit es
sehe mich wird und die ganze flüssigkeit quasi
ja ein deck heftig mit und ich freue mich auch
kein knoblauch ich habe aber gar nicht schmeckt
echt lecker macht unbedingt nach und ich komme
doch schon zum ende des videos und ich hoffe
es hat euch gefallen das war ja teil zu weinen
also ich wünsche euch dass ganz viel spaß
zum nachmachen und schaut in die info boxer
stehen alle ganz genauen mengenangaben und
dann will ich mal sagen bis zum nächsten mal
auf den sketchen tschüss es ist einfach
direkt für die ganze familie ist heftig